on an auspicious day in november of 1986
five australian miners climbed lunatic
hill
so named for the mental state anyone
would be in
to dig them while their competitors
searched for opals at a depth of two to
five meters
the lunatic hill syndicate board 20
meters into the earth and for their
audacity
the earth rewarded them with a
fist-sized record-breaking
opal they named it the halley's comet
opal
after the much larger rocky icy body
flying by the earth at that
time the halley's comet opal is a marvel
but its uniqueness is paradoxically the
most
usual thing about it while diamonds
rubies emeralds and other precious
stones are often
indistinguishably similar no two opals
look the same
thanks to a characteristic called play
of color
this shimmering dazzling dancing display
of light
comes about from a confluence of
chemistry geology
and optics that define opals from their
earliest moments
deep underground it's there that an opal
begins its life as something
surprisingly abundant water
trickling down through gaps in soil and
rock water flows through sandstone
limestone and basalt picking up a
microscopic
compound called silicon dioxide
this silica enriched water enters the
voids inside
pieces of volcanic rock prehistoric
riverbeds
wood and even the bones of ancient
creatures
gradually the water starts to evaporate
and the silica solution begins forming a
gel
within which millions of silica spheres
form
layer by layer as a series of concentric
shells the gel ultimately hardens into a
glass-like material
and the spheres settle into a lattice
structure
the vast majority of the time this
structure is
haphazard resulting in common or potch
opals
with unremarkable exteriors the tiny
mesmerizing percentage we call precious
opals
have regions where silica beads of
uniform size
form orderly arrays so
why do those structures produce such
vibrant
displays the answer lies in a principle
of
wave physics called interference
for the sake of simplicity let's look at
what happens when a single color of
light
green with a wavelength of 500
nanometers hits
a precious opal the green light will
scatter throughout the gemstone
and reflect back with varying
intensities
from most angles suffused from some
entirely dimmed
and others dazzlingly bright what's
happening
is some of the green light reflects off
of the top layer
some reflects off of the layer below
that and so on
when the additional distance it travels
from one layer to the next and back
is a multiple of the wavelength such as
500 or 1000 extra nanometers
the crests and valleys of the waves
match each other
this phenomenon is called constructive
interference
and it amplifies the wave producing a
brighter color
so if you position your eye at the
correct angle
the green light reflecting from many
layers
adds together shift the angle just a bit
and you change the distance the light
travels between layers
change it enough and you'll reach a
point where the crests
match the valleys making the waves
cancel each other out
that's destructive interference
different colors have different
wavelengths which translates to varying
distances they have to travel
to constructively interfere that's why
colors roughly correspond to silica bead
sizes
the spaces between 210 nanometer beads
are just right to amplify blue light
for red light with its long wavelengths
the silica beads must be close to
300 nanometers those take a very long
time to form
and because of that red is the rarest
opal color
the differences in the arrangements of
the gel lattices within a particular
stone
result in a wide range of color patterns
everything from broad flash to pin fire
to the ultra rare harlequin the
circumstances that lead to the formation
of precious opal
are so uncommon that they only occur in
a handful of places
about 95 percent come from australia
where an ancient inland sea created the
perfect conditions
it was there that the halley's comet
opal formed some
100 million years ago which raises the
question
in the next 100 million years silica
rich water will percolate through the
nooks and crannies of some of the
discarded artifacts of human
civilization
what opalescent plays of light will one
day
radiate from the things we forget in the
darkness
not all precious materials are quite so
native to our planet
guess where gold comes from outer space
learn more about the extraterrestrial
origins of one of earth's most
precious metals with this video
you